teniendo en cuenta esto que decíamos no
que es necesario el consentimiento
unánime de todos los miembros de la otan
para que otras naciones se adhieran qué
efectos tiene que usted la oposición de
turquía podría trabar definitivamente
las aspiraciones de suecia y de
finlandia
donde hago mucho gusto saludarte y
respondiendo a tu atinada pregunta que
me hizo un planteamiento que ya se está
dando en bruselas pero también en
washington
me parece que pues turquía avanzará en
esa oposición y me parece también
importante considerar que hay argumentos
más allá de la situación de los grupos
terroristas y todo lo que salía en la
nota previa por el lado del grupo étnico
de los kurdos y su vinculación con las
guerrillas internas en turquía desde
1984 me parece que las alarmas se
encienden porque esto duplicaría la
frontera de todas estas naciones
miembros de la otan con respecto a rusia
santiago ahora a recep tayyip erdogán
argumenta que estas naciones son como
decíamos también el hogar de grupos
terroristas y dijo además que no quiere
repetir lo que considera un error no
cuando se permitió el ingreso de grecia
de qué se trata ese antecedente griego y
que implicó para turquía
ambas naciones ingresaron en 1952 sin
embargo cuando hubo un conflicto que
sabemos que las partes de los conflictos
técnicos siempre traen un gran
componente cultural y se convierte
después en una situación geopolítica
entonces cuando sucede una confrontación
entre turquía y chipre entonces grecia
se sale porque considera que la alianza
militar que hoy conocemos como lo tal
nos respondió como debería de ser sin
embargo para que pudiera regresar grecia
a ser miembro de la otan tuvo que tener
el respaldo de todos los países y ahí
turquía pues tuvo que
finalmente aceptar que se reincorporará
grecia sin embargo hemos visto que estas
fronteras marítimas y aéreas y toda la
complejidad de la problemática entre
grecia y turquía que ya data desde hace
décadas atrás pues no se ha resuelto y
por eso es que hoy está sobre la mesa
esta situación donde estamos viendo que
la organización es decir la expansión de
la otan no va a venir a resolver
conflicto social a nivel hoy trascendió
además que rusia va a dejar de
suministrar electricidad a partir del
próximo sábado a finlandia si bien no
dijeron no que se trata de una medida en
represalia cree usted que puede ser
efectivo para rusia utilizar sus
recursos sus recursos perdón para frenar
los distintos ingresos a la otan
fíjate que estamos viendo que en esta
guerra híbrida además que vamos a seguir
viendo que hay una ciberguerra que corre
en paralelo cuanto a los ataques
cibernéticos de rusia hacia algunas
naciones de occidente
estamos viendo que tampoco tiene mucho
margen de acción rusia entonces una un
mecanismo es justo lo que vimos hace un
par de semanas de exigir que el pago de
los energéticos que europa importa de
rusia sea a través del uso del rublo y
otro es justo esto que estamos viendo de
que ya a partir de próximas horas siendo
sábado allá en europa
finlandia tendrá que buscar alternativas
energéticas porque esto es apenas el
inicio de alguna reacción por parte del
gobierno del kremlin esto apenas
comienza y lo he venido diciendo en
algunos momentos y situaciones santiago
cada vez que
suecia y finlandia cada vez se acercaban
a esta posibilidad este domingo suecia
nos dirá si efectivamente también
oficializa su ingreso a votar
parece un error porque el único que
genera es encender más las alarmas por
lado de rúsia y esto lo que genera es
alargar y prolongar la agonía y por lo
tanto está mucho más lejos el camino
para llegar finalmente a hablar de un
posible acuerdo de paz